they knew the country would need a
firewall to keep partisan flames from
scorching scorching our Republican so
they created the Senate out of necessity
James Madison wrote of some stable
institution in the government of some
stable institution in the government
today we will fulfill this founding
purpose we will reject this incoherent
case that comes nowhere near nowhere
near justifying the first presidential
removal in history this partisan
impeachment will end today but I fear
the threat to our institutions may not
because this episode is one of a symptom
of something much deeper in the last
three years the opposition to this
president has come to revolve around a
truly dangerous concept if you are just
joining us we could be anywhere from
five to fifteen maybe twenty minutes
away from the Senate vote on impeachment
we learned that Republican Mitt Romney
would vote to convict Donald Trump on
one of the two counts but not the other
Charles Schumer has already spoken Mitch
McConnell now speaking what is
invariably going to be the acquittal of
President Trump welcome we are here we
are seeing corruption in the flesh as I
see people saying in the chat welcomed
on Twitch YouTube and Facebook live
we're here I will take your questions as
we listen to Mitch McConnell it is a
very very sad day on election
it accepts a fee it reflects andrey
tools but not this time within months
Secretary Clinton was suggesting her
defeat was invalid she called our
president illegitimate former president
falsely claimed that President Trump
didn't actually win he lost the election
the former president says and members of
Congress have used similar rhetoric a
disinformation campaign weakening
confidence in our democracy the very
real issue of foreign election
interference was abused to fuel
conspiracy theories for years prominent
voices said it had been a secret
conspiracy between the president's
campaign and a foreign government but
when the Muller investigation and the
Senate Intelligence Committee debunked
out the D legitimizing Endeavour waffles
der awful says be a super chat in the
president in the future any president
can do what he wants everyone knows this
only applies to Republicans as Democrats
are held to a higher standard by their
voters very well said Trump in November
that election will be presumptively
invalid as well that's chairmanship on
this floor the funny thing about this is
if Trump loses in November he's going to
say the election was rigged invalid and
it's going to cause a shitstorm but as
well
so they still don't still don't accept
the American voters last decision and
now they're preparing Jackie Tupper says
via super chat donate to their
competition yes that's effectively what
you're doing Jackie thank you not only
the last decision but the next decision
heads we win tails you cheated and who
can trust our democracy anyway they say
this kind of talk creates more fear and
division that our foreign adversaries
could achieve in their wildest dreams as
dr. hill testified our adversary he
would know he's been blocking
investigations into foreign interference
just each other
degrade our institutions and destroy the
faith of the American people in our
democracy and as she noted if Americans
become consumed by partisan rancor we
can easily do that work for them the
architects of this impeachment claimed
they were defending norms and traditions
in reality it was an assault on both
first the house attacked its own
precedents on fairness and due process
and by rushing to use the impeachment
power as a political weapon of first
resort then there are articles attack
the office of the presidency then they
attack the Senate and called us
treacherous then the far-left tried to
impugn the chief justice for remaining
neutral during the trial and now and now
for the final act the Speaker of the
House is trying to steal the Senate's
sole power to render a verdict
speaker says she'll just refuse to
accept this acquittal speaker the house
says she refuses to accept this
acquittal whatever that means
perhaps you will tear up the verdict
like she tore up the State of the Union
address
what a joke even even colleagues across
the aisle is this really another super
chat coming in from ron hubbard you sell
your Tesla yesterday at 9:50 now it's
7:30 I'm just holding my friend I'm too
busy following what's going on in the
world to be trading stocks at all attack
institutions until they get their way
even my colleagues you may not agree
with this president must see the
insanity of this logic it's like saying
you're so worried about a bull in a
china shop that you want to bulldoze the
china shop to chased it out mm-hmm and
here's the most troubling part the most
troubling part tell us Mitch
there is no sign this attack on our
institutions will end here in recent
months Democratic presidential
candidates and Senate leaders have toyed
with killing and filibuster so the
Senate could approve radical changes
with less deliberation or less
persuasion unfortunately this is live so
I can't put it at 1.5 X speed or
threatening political retribution if the
justices did not decide a case the way
they wanted we've seen proposals to turn
the FEC the regulator of elections and
political speech into a partisan body
for the first time ever all these things
mr. president I do not Jimmy big nuts
says David did you hear Joe Biden's
Freudian slip after Iowa I feel good
about getting more than our fair share
of Delegates I didn't see it
tristin Clemens says these people will
do anything to stop Sanders civil war we
will talk about that not the topic of
today though Trump's acquittal the topic
of today Ryan no wiki says do you think
establishment Democrat Democrats and
Republicans would try to bring
impeachment to Bernie at some point if
he wins the presidential race if
what charges most likely now I mean Ryan
oh that's the it's that would be
completely irresponsible speculation at
this point recklessness the Senate was
created to stop the response to losing
one election cannot be to attack the
office of the presidency which of course
isn't happening let me say thank you to
tatiana rodriguez who is new member
number 166 using the impeach fifty
coupon code and also re kenya zev who is
number 167 this is the last day of
impeachment this is the last day of the
coupon code impeach fifty all right we
are close to our goal of 200 members
using that code consider using it today
at join pakman.com the last opportunity
as we are potentially just minutes from
the acquittal of president donald trump
the way as Madison and Hamilton intended
the institution's must break the fever
rather than the other way around how
many S's are there an institution is
built to Senate to keep temporary rage
from doing permanent damage to our
republic the framers built the Senate to
keep temporary rage from doing permanent
damage to our republic that mr.
president is what we will do when we end
this precedent breaking impeachment I
hope we will look back on this vote and
say this was the day the fever began to
break we will not know I hope we will
not say this was just the beginning
- animus consent the Senate stand in
recess subject to the call of the chair
without objection
the Senate stands in recess subject to
the call of the chair what on earth just
happened it froze at a very strange
moment okay so now they are in recess
let's see if we are told I'm just
finding out what's going on let's see if
we are told when it is there with words
from the Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
the Senate impeachment trial of
President Donald Trump coming to a close
votes are next on the two articles of
impeachment although yesterday power and
obstruction of Congress after some 78
members of the Senate spoke on the floor
41 Democrats 37 Republicans by our count
and they should be gaveling back in
momentarily the Chief Justice John
Roberts arrived at the Capitol about 15
or 20 minutes ago expecting a vote in
Donald Trump's Senate impeachment trial
any minute let me say thank you to David
Kahne who has who has just signed up at
joined pakman.com and his new net member
number 168 we have been streaming the
impeachment proceedings for weeks at
this point it is finally coming to a
close today and one that will simply not
be satisfactory to anyone who believes
that trials should have evidence and
trials should have witnesses and trials
should be adjudicated by jurors who come
in with an open mind willing to be
convinced by evidence willing to listen
to what it is that is going to be
presented rather than knowing in advance
that they will be voting to acquit I
encourage you to help us reach this very
ambitious goal of 200 new members using
our impeach 50 coupon code we're at 168
and we've been carrying over the goal
from day one and I would I look forward
to welcoming some additional folks
welcome if you are watching on youtube
twitch or Facebook we are live on all of
those platforms and we are waiting for
what is potentially just minutes away an
impeachment vote which will by every
indication
lead to the acquittal of President
Donald Trump in what is only the third
impeachment trial in American history
Andrew Johnson in the 1800's acquitted
Bill Clinton in the 1900s acquitted and
now Donald Trump in the year 2020 almost
guaranteed to be acquitted Mitt Romney a
Republican who did say he would be
voting to convict Donald Trump on one
article but would be voting to acquit on
the other article we are witnessing
history here truly let me see what is on
people's minds via super Chad Zachary
Monroe says we all need a joke during
these frustrating times what is Donald
Trump's favorite type of clothes
clothing answer Russian ties all right
Jason Ealing says impeachment was
hopeless the Republican Party has blind
loyalty
Andy O'Neil says nobody vote for Andrew
yin who wants to take $1,000 from you
each month Andy you seem confused about
many things more things than I am able
to straighten you out about today that
is for damn sure my friend by I
appreciate the $5 super chat also thanks
over on twitch for the hundred bits from
ODP who said what did Oh deep e say Oh
DP said this whole thing is so dumb
Democrats has many of these same
positions during the Clinton impeachment
why didn't they just focus on actually
doing [ __ ] for the next nine months and
then vote the orange [ __ ] out nobody
clipped that please Ryan Henry Dean says
via super Chad do you believe MIT is
being sincere or revenge
nose looks like they are gaveling back
in here's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date the deputy sergeant at arms will
make the proclamation hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep
silence on pain of imprisonment while
the Senate of the United States is
sitting for the trial of the articles of
impeachment exhibited by the House of
Representatives
against Donald John Trump President of
the United States as a reminder to
everyone in the chamber as well as those
in the galleries demonstrations of
approval or disapproval are prohibited
strictly the majority leader is
recognized the Chief Justice the Senate
is now ready to vote on the articles of
impeachment and after that is done we
will adjourn the court of impeachment
Wow
it's a clerk will now read the first
article of impeachment
oh no article 1 abuse of power the
Constitution provides that the House of
Representatives quote shall have the
sole power of impeachment unquote and
that the president quote shall be
removed from office on impeachment for
and conviction of treason bribery as
they continue to read let me say thank
you to Ian Breslin Ian Breslin is new
member 169 using the impeach 50 coupon
code 169 coupon code impeach 50 does
save you 50% at join pakman.com Andy
O'Neill says it was a yin and yang joke
I'll see myself out
all right thank you very much Trump
Beatles says Andy's Andrew yen thing was
a joke yin yang I understand thank you
very much we are in the middle of
reading article 1 and soon there will be
a vote Ukraine in the 2020 United States
presidential election he did so through
a scheme or course of conduct that
included soliciting the government of
Ukraine to publicly announce
investigations that would benefit his
reelection harm the election prospects
of a political opponent and influenced
the 2020 United States presidential
election to his advantage President
Trump also sought to pressure the
government of Ukraine to take these
steps by conditioning official United
States government acts of significant
value to Ukraine on its public
announcement of the investigations
President Trump
engaged in this scheme or course of
conduct for corrupt purposes in pursuit
of personal political benefits let me
say thank you to tactical wookie for
subscribing with twitch Prime as well as
Pogue Mahone 66u to our subscribers
eight
75 and 876 on Twitch president Trump
engaged in this scheme or course of
conduct through the following means one
president Trump acting both directly and
through his agents within and outside
the United States government correctly
solicited the government of Ukraine to
publicly announce investigations into a
a political opponent former vice
president Joseph R Biden Jr and be a
discredited theory promoted by Russia
alleging that Ukraine rather than Russia
interfered in the 2016 United States
presidential election - that's a mouth
same corrupt motives President Trump
acting both directly and through his
agents within the outside of the United
States government conditioned to
official acts on the public
announcements that he had requested a
the release of 391 million dollars of
the United States taxpayer funds that
Congress had appropriated on a
bipartisan basis for the purpose of
providing vital military and security
assistance to Ukraine to oppose Russian
aggression in which President Trump had
ordered suspended and be a head of state
meeting at the White House which the
president of Ukraine sought to
demonstrate continued United States
support for the government of Ukraine in
the face of Russian aggression three
faced with the public revelation of his
actions President Trump
ultimately released the military and
security assistance to the government of
Ukraine and has persisted in openly and
let me say thank you to Alexandra
Galadriel who is new member number 170
at join pakman.com you know we've heard
these articles of impeachment many times
I am going to prioritize hearing from
people these are available online and a
couple people seem mad that I'm talking
over stuff but we you know we've heard
these multiple times they're online it's
very hard to even really understand when
these things are being read in this
endless monotone so I want to hear from
you Dan stepka says twitch donuts don't
show in super chat dumb yeah super chat
is a YouTube feature let me say thank
you to David Dittmer David Dittmer is
new member number 171 we are only 29
members from the incredibly ambitious
goal of 200
I also want to say there was a message
over on twitch that I missed no there is
not all right we will go back to the
droning monotone but under the United
States each senator when his or her name
is called will stand in his or her place
and vote guilty or not guilty as
required by rule 23 of the Senate rules
unimpeached
I'll keep track here article 1 section 3
of the Constitution regarding the vote
required for conviction on impeachment
provides that no person shall be
convicted without the concurrence of
two-thirds of the members present that
means 67 the question is on the first
article of impeachment senators house au
is the respondent Donald John Trump
guilty or not guilty a roll call vote is
required will call the roll
mr. Alexander mr. Alexander not guilty
miss Baldwin oh they have it on screen
miss Baldwin guilty folks mr. Barroso
not guilty this is the acquittal of
Donald Johnson Bennett mr. Bennett
guilty mrs. Blackburn mrs. Blackburn not
guilty mr. Blumenthal mr. Blumenthal
guilty mr. blunt mr. blunt not guilty as
soon as 34 say not guilty it is not
automatically over guilty mr. Boozman
mr. Bozeman not guilty mr. Braun mr.
Braun not guilty mr. Brown mr. Brown
guilty mr. Bourg mr. burr not guilty
Miss Cantwell
Miss Cantwell guilty mrs. capito mrs.
capito not guilty mr. carton
mr. Cardin guilty mr. Carper mr. Carper
guilty mr. Casey
mr. Casey guilty mr. Cassidy mr. Cassidy
not guilty
this is it folks this is the vote
articles why Holland's not guilty mr.
Coons mr. Coons guilty mr. Cornyn mr.
Cornyn not guilty mr. Cortes Masto miss
Cortez Masto guilty mr. Kahn mr. cotton
not guilty mr. Kramer
mr. Kramer not guilty
mr. Crapo mr. Crapo not guilty mr. Cruz
remember 34 knows and it shows not
guilty mr. Danes mr. Danes not guilty
mr. duckworth mr. duckworth guilty mr.
Durban mr. Durban guilty mr. NZ mr. NZ
mouthing guillotine from prison feeling
like you got him acquitted when it was
like a foregone conclusion not guilty
mrs. Feinstein mrs. Feinstein guilty
mrs. Fisher was touch and go with
Feinstein for a bit mrs. Fisher not
guilty mr. Gardner mr. Gardner not
guilty mrs. Gillibrand mrs. Gillibrand
guilty mr. Graham mr. Graham little
cheese
sit down Grassley mr. Grassley not
guilty miss Harris
miss Harris is kamala guilty guilty
miss Hassan miss Hassan guilty mr.
Hawley mr. Hawley
not guilty mr. Heinrich mr. Heinrich
guilty mr. onoe you're just joining us
this is article
Oh No guilty mr. ho 11 more votes is
driven not guilty mrs. Hyde Smith mrs.
Hyde Smith not guilty mr. Inhofe mr.
Inhofe not guilty mr. Johnson mr.
Johnson not guilty mr. Jones mr. Jones
guilty mr. Caine mr. Caine guilty mr.
Kennedy mr. Kennedy not guilty mr. king
mr. king guilty was halfway there that's
50 votes was clover char guilty guilty
say me mr. lankford not guilty mr. Lahey
mr. Lahey guilty mr. Lee mr. Lee no more
not guilty votes with the President on
article 1 sister or not guilty
mr. mansion mr. mansion guilty mr.
markey mr. mark ed markey
guilty guy mr. MacConnell not guilty mr.
MacConnell not guilty miss mcsalley
miss mcsalley one more vote will do it
Leon gentlemen the president will be
acquitted on article 1 mr. Menendez mr.
Menendez guilty mr. Merkley mr. Merkley
guilty mr. Moran mr. Moran there it is
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States Donald Trump has been
acquitted on article 1 of use of power
Kowski not guilty mr. Murphy mr. Murphy
he Lisa Murkowski miss alarm Italy of
course voting not guilty predicted
guilty mr. Paul mr. Paul not guilty mr.
Purdue
mr. Perdue not guilty mr. Peters
mr. Peters guilty mr. Portman mr.
Portman not guilty mr. Reid if you're
just joining us Donald Trump just
seconds ago acquitted on article one
abuse of power mr. rishe not guilty mr.
roberts mr. roberts not guilty mr.
Romney mr. Romney guilty Romney voting
guilty an interesting nose that will be
an asterisk at the end of this MIT
Romney voters guilty mr. rounds and no
doubt will be the target of Donald
Schneider for a while mr. Rubio not
guilty Mr Sanders Mr Sanders guilty mr.
sad Bernie Sanders voting guilty mr.
sass not guilty mr. schat's mr. schat's
guilty mr. Schumer mr. Schumer guilty
mr. Scott of Florida mr. Scott of
Florida that's Rick Scott as opponent
Scott Menzel Scott of South Carolina
there he is mr. Scott of South Carolina
not guilty mr. Shaheen mrs. Shaheen
guilty mr. Shelby mr. Shelby not guilty
miss cinema miss cinema guilty mr. Smith
mrs. Smith guilty mr. dobyne Oh stabenow
guilty just 13 nodes ago mr. Sullivan
not guilty mr. Chester mr. tester guilty
mr. Thoon mr. Thoon not guilty mr.
Tillis mr. Tillis not guilty mr. Toomy
mystery to me not guilty
expected utility to 248 mr. Udall guilty
mr. Van Hollen
mr. Van Hollen guilty mr. Warner mr.
Warner
guilty miss Warren miss Warren guilty
mr. Whitehouse mr. Whitehouse guilty mr.
wicker mr. wicker not guilty mr. Wyden
mr. Wyden guilty mr. young mr. young not
guilty and there it is
president Donald Trump acquitted on
article 1 abuse of power MIT Romney the
only Republican senator voting guilty
the clerk will now report the results
momentarily typically they ask if
anybody wants to change their vote
expecting 53 to 47 on article 2 MIT
Romney will likely vote not guilty on
article 2 you're just joining us this is
the acquittal of President Donald Trump
in a sham trial with no witnesses not
really an accomplishment for anybody
Donald Trump's lawyers having a very
easy task simply having to not fall down
basically a foregone conclusion from the
start the only real surprise surprise
Mitt Romney the only Republican to vote
guilty on article 1
let me say thanks to Shane Busta bûche
de subscriber number what's the article
of impeachment 48 senators have
pronounced Donald John Trump President
of the United States guilty as charged
52 senators have pronounced him not
guilty as charged
two-thirds of the Senators present not
having pronounced him guilty the Senate
our judges that the respondent Donald
John Trump President of the United
States is not guilty as charged in the
first article of impeachment the clerk
will read the second article of
impeachment so now they will read
article two again we've heard these
articles many times you can find them
online so I will continue to answer
super chats while they read I do want to
thank Josie Breton who is new member
number 173 you want to make sure I don't
forget to thank anybody Julie Fung is
number 174 and Darlene Sinclair is
number 175 we are just 25 new members
from a very very steep goal of 200 the
coupon code impeach 50 does save you 50%
on my website Timmy Lunsford asked via
super chat why am i watching this I
don't know Bradford Betts has signed up
on YouTube Kellan sends a super chat we
will listen to a bit of article 2
violation of his constitutional duty to
take care that the laws be faithfully
executed Donald J Trump has directed the
unprecedented categorical and
indiscriminate
defiance of subpoenas Daniel Krieger
says we all knew this would happen but
I'm still sad we did not we did know it
would happen and yet it is still I mean
it's even if you know the outcome when
you see the Sham nature of this conclude
with a final point of you know Romney
voted guilty on article 1 and likely
will vote not guilty on article 2 how
can you not feel as though justice
clearly was not done
we are waiting now on article 2 they
will vote momentarily it is undertaking
the investigation served subpoenas
seeking documents and testimony deemed
vital to the inquiry from various
feet of brands agencies and offices
thanks to Jacob Posner for the member
additions in response without lawful
cause or excuse
president Trump directed executive
branch agencies offices and officials
not to comply with those subpoenas
president Trump thus interposed the
powers of the presidency against the
local subpoenas of the House of
Representatives and assumed to himself
functions and judgments necessary to the
exercise of the sole power of
impeachment vested by the Constitution
in the House of Representatives
President Trump
abused the powers of his high office to
the following means one directing the
White House to defy a lawful subpoena by
withholding the production of documents
sought their end by the committee's to
directing other executive branch
agencies and offices to defy lawful
subpoenas and withhold the production of
documents and records from the
committee's in response to which the
Department of State Office of Management
and Budget Department of Energy and
Department of Defense refused to produce
a single document or record three
directing current and former executive
branch officials not to cooperate with
the committee's in response to which
nine administration officials defied
subpoenas for testimony namely John
Michael Mick Mulvaney Robert B Blair
John a Eisenberg Michael Ellis Kristen
Wells Griffith Russell T vog Michael
Duffy Bryan McCormack and T Ulrich Brett
ball these actions were consistent with
president Trump's previous efforts to
undermine United States government
investigations into foreign interference
in United States elections through these
actions president Trump saw to arrogate
to himself the right to determine the
propriety scope and nature of an
impeachment inquiry into his own conduct
as well as the you know a you know
lateral prerogative to deny any and all
information to the House of
Representatives in the exercise of its
sole power of impeachment in the history
of the Republic no president has ever
ordered the complete defiance of an
impeachment inquiry or sought to
obstruct and impede so comprehensively
the ability
of the House of Representatives to
investigate high crimes and misdemeanors
this abuse of office served to cover up
the president's own repeated misconduct
and to seize and control the power of
impeachment and thus to nullify a vital
constitutional safeguard vested solely
in the House of Representatives in all
of this President Trump has acted in a
manner contrary to his trust as
president and subversive of the
constitutional government to the great
prejudice of the cause of law and
justice and to the manifest injury of
the people of the United States
wherefore President Trump by such
conduct has demonstrated that he will
remain a threat to the Constitution if
allowed to remain in office and has
acted in a manner grossly incompatible
with self governance and the rule of law
president Trump thus warrants
impeachment and trial removal from
office and disqualification to hold and
enjoy any office of honor trust or
profit under the United States and now
they Westerners on the second article of
impeachment senators house au is the
respondent Donald John Trump guilty or
not guilty the clerk will call the roll
already history will examine article 1
not guilty Ms Baldwin guilty mr. Barroso
only difference you're expecting here is
Romney to vote Noster Bennett guilty
expecting 53:37 not guilty mr.
Blumenthal guilty mr. blunt
not guilty mr. Booker guilty mr. Bozeman
not guilty mr. Braun not guilty
mr. Braun guilty mr. burr not guilty MS
Cantwell
guilty mrs. capito not guilty mr. Cardin
guilty mr. Carper guilty mr. Casey
guilty mr. Cassidy not guilty
mrs. Collins not guilty they go
alphabetic in four people wondering
guilty mr. Cornyn not guilty miss Cortez
Masto guilty mr. cotton not guilty mr.
Kramer
not guilty
mr. Crapo not guilty mr. Cruz Oh guilty
mr. Danes
not guilty miss Duckworth guilty mr.
Durban guilty mr. Enzi not guilty miss
Ernst not guilty mrs. Feinstein guilty
mrs. Fisher not guilty mr. Gardner not
guilty mrs. Gillibrand
you're just joining us this is for the
great article to Trump already acquitted
on article one mr. Grassley not guilty
miss Harris guilty miss Hassan on
article one Romney the only Republican
to vote guilty histor Holly expecting
not guilty on are denied guilty mr.
Heinrich guilty mr. Ono guilty mr.
Hoeven not guilty mrs. Hyde Smith not
guilty mr. Inhofe not guilty mr. Johnson
not guilty mr. Jones guilty mr. Kane
guilty mr. Kennedy not guilty mr. king
guilty his club achar guilty mr.
lankford not guilty mr. lahey guilty mr.
Lee not guilty
mrs. Leffler minutes from the acquittal
on our team who will Donald Trump mr.
mansion guilty mr. markey guilty mr.
MacConnell not guilty ms mcsalley not
guilty mr. Menendez guilty mr. Merkley
guilty mr. Moran not guilty
ms Murkowski not guilty no surprise to
Murphy guilty mrs. Marie
guilty mr. Paul not guilty mr. Purdue
and Donald Trump is acquitted you
remember you need to feed our guilty
which means once you get to 34 not
guilty it is over and that is it the
President of the United States has been
acquitted oscar robles article 1 & 2
guilty mr. rish only question is up next
romney how does he vote not guilty
mr. Roberts oh no one more not guilty
mr. Romney not guilty and there is a
reason 3 to 47 will be the final MIT
Romney the one Republican to vote guilty
on the one voting not guilty on article
two not guilty mr. Rubio not guilty mr.
Sanders guilty
mr. sass not guilty mr. schat's guilty
mr. Schumer guilty mr. Scott of Florida
not guilty mr. Scott of South Carolina
not guilty mr. Shaheen guilty mr. Shelby
not guilty
Miz cinema guilty Miss Smith guilty miss
Stabenow guilty mr. Sullivan not guilty
mr. tester guilty mr. Thoon not guilty
mr. tellus not guilty mr. Toomy just
nine to go not guilty mr. Udall guilty
mr. Van Hollen Elizabeth Warren upcoming
guilty mr. Warner guilty MS Warren
guilty mr. Whitehouse
guilty mr. wicker not guilty mr. Wyden
and there it is mr. young not 53 ot2 47
exactly as predicted they will now
Italia the votes Donald Trump has been
acquitted on all charges with no
witnesses with a very very pleased Mitch
McConnell and we now go back to sort of
pretending this never happened Donald
Trump will campaign on an exoneration
Donald Trump recently polling on the
Gallup approval poll 49% the highest
that he has had all presidency this may
well reinvigorate the Trump base and it
is not an uncertain not a surprising
result let me say thanks to Howard Hall
whose new member number 177 I appreciate
that Howard on this article of
impeachment 47 senators have pronounced
Donald John Trump President of the
United States guilty as charged
53 senators have pronounced him not
guilty as charged
two-thirds of the Senators present not
having pronounced him guilty the senator
judges that respondent Donald John Trump
President of the United States is not
guilty as charged
in the second article of impeachment
they will now move to end the trial
formally and return the Senate to normal
residing officer directs judgment to be
entered in accordance with the judgment
of the Senate as follows the Senate
having tried Donald John Trump President
of the United States
upon two articles of impeachment
exhibited against him by the House of
Representatives and two-thirds of the
Senators present not having found him
guilty of the charges contained therein
it is therefore ordered and adjudged
that the said Donald John Trump be and
he is hereby acquitted of the charges
and said articles there it is folks as
Chief Justice the majority leader is
recognized I sent an order to the desk
clerk will report
[Music]
likely a formal measure to end the
Senate as an impeachment court ordered
the secretary be directed to communicate
to the Secretary of State as provided by
rule 23 of the rules of procedure and
practice in the Senate when sitting on
impeachment trials and also to the House
of Representatives the judgment of the
Senate in the case of Donald John Trump
and transmit a certified copy of the
judgment to each without objection the
order will be entered mr. chief justice
the majority leader is recognized before
this process fully concludes I want to
very quickly acknowledge a few of the
people who helped the Senate for duty
here's a list of the people who helped
with this sham trial first and foremost
I know my colleagues join me in thanking
Chief Justice Roberts for presiding over
the Senate trial with a clear head
steady hand and the forbearance that
this rare occasion demands give me a
break here can you imagine
so who's not clapping
we know full well that his presence is
our presiding officer came in addition
to not instead of his day job across the
street so the sunnat' thanks to chief
justice and his staff who helped him
perform this unique role like his
predecessor chief justice rehnquist the
Senate will be awarding Chief Justice
Roberts the golden gavel to commemorate
his time presiding over this body this
is like hours in the chair but I think
we can agree the chief justice has put
in his due and then some participation
trophies were the chief justice I mean
this is the this is the the bottom of
the barrel of American government it's
it's unbelievable you very much of
course there are countless Senate
professionals whose efforts were
essential I have more thorough thanks to
offer next week to all of those teams
from the Secretary of the Senate's
office to the parliamentarians
sergeant-at-arms team and beyond but
there are two more groups I'd like to
single out now first the two different
classes of Senate pages who participated
in this trial their footwork and cool
under pressure literally kept the floor
running our current class came on board
right in the middle of the third
presidential impeachment trial in
American history and quickly found
themselves hand-delivering a hundred and
eighty question cards from senators desk
to the Dyess no pressure right guys
everybody gets participation fees and
it's a sham trial amazing
imagine cheering up with this processor
six-second define men and women of the
capital police
we know that the safety of our democracy
literally rests in their hands every
single day but the heightened measures
surrounding the trial meant even more
hours and even more work and even more
vigilance thank you all very much for
your service to this body and to the
country
[Applause]
chair recognizes the Democratic leaders
I joined the Republican leader in
thanking the personnel who aided the
Senate over the past several weeks
Capitol Police do an outstanding job
day-in day-out to protect the members of
this chamber their staffs the press and
everyone who works in and visits this
Capitol finds think anybody has in work
extra shifts and in greater numbers to
provide additional security over the
past three weeks thank you to every one
of them I too would like to thank those
wonderful pages and Doc you guys join
you with your Feinstein status is
walking down right here and giving the
Chief Justice our questions as the
leader noted the new class of pages
started midway in this impeachment trial
when you take a new job you're usually
given a few days to take stock of things
get up to speed this class was given no
such leeway but they stepped right in
didn't miss a beat ferrying hundreds of
questions from US senators to the Chief
Justice the performance is undisguised
is not how most kursk on the first week
at work but they did it with aplomb I'd
also like to extend my personal thank
you today that Houck the director of the
Office of accessibility services
Thailand pumphrey the supervisor and
Grace Ridgeway the wonderful director of
capital facilities everyone graces
everyone graces team on Grace's team
worked so hard to make sure we were
ready for impeachment
Gary Richardson known affectionately to
us as tiny the chief chamber attended
Jim Hoover and the capper and the
cabinet shop who built new cabinets to
deprive us of the use of our electronics
and flip phones during the trial yeah by
the way I see I see all the trumpets
showing up in my YouTube feed and in my
twitch stream feel free to do what it
seems you all do when you start
commenting on my videos which is engage
caps lock and disable spellcheck we're
ready for it and
again grace we appreciate all your hard
work please convey our sincerest thanks
to your staff thank you all the whole
staff for your diligent work through
many long days and late nights during
this very trying time in our nation's
history
shuco and the chair also wishes to make
a very brief statement now great I would
like to begin by thanking the majority
leader and the Democratic leader for
their support as I attempted to carry
out ill-defined responsibilities in an
unfamiliar setting this is what I think
about this ensured that I had wise
counsel of the Senate itself through its
secretary and her legislative staff I am
especially grateful to the
parliamentarian and her deputy for their
unfailing patience and keen insight
I am likewise grateful to the
sergeant-at-arms and his staff for the
assistance and many courtesies that they
extended during my period of required
residency and thank you all for making
my presence here as comfortable as
possible as I depart the chamber I do so
with an invitation to visit the court by
long tradition and in memory of the 135
years we sat in this building we keep
the front row of the gallery in our
court room open for members of Congress
who might want to drop by to see an
argument or to escape one dude come on
I also depart with sincere good wishes
as we carry out our common commitment to
the Constitution through the distinct
roles assigned to us by that charter you
have been generous hosts and I look
forward to seeing you again under
happier circumstances the majority
leader I move that the Senate sitting as
a court of impeachment only articles
against Donald John Trump adjourned
sunny does without objection the motion
is agreed to the Senate sitting as a
court of impeachment stands adjourned
sigh need I sign and I my friends sign
and die the conclusion of the inge
acquittal of Donald John Trump Frederick
Kolbert thank you you are new member
number 178
this is it folks this is the beginning
of the end or the end of the beginning
or just part 7 of 752 this is going to
be a notable year in American politics
we have extreme levels of drama already
in the first Democratic primary the Iowa
caucus we have the president now totally
exonerated as all of the caps-lock crew
is I think that's what we're gonna call
the trumpets that raid my channel the
caps lock crew I see a lot a lot of
drama in what is left of this year up
through and including the November 3rd
election Justice John Roberts is leaving
the chamber looks like a company is that
loony Lindsey that is loony Lindsey
Graham right and yes
Dianne Feinstein there and Capitol
Police of course keeping order the
Senate chamber slowly emptying as the
president of the United States has been
acquitted on both charges the votes
almost identical 52 to 48 in favor of
acquittal on article 1 Mitt Romney
Willard mittens Romney the only
Republican to vote guilty a Willard not
voting guilty on article 2 where it was
53 to 47 you see the impeachment
managers exiting and that is going to do
it ladies and gentlemen that is it we
are going to get back I've got a million
things to do I did want to get in here
for the actual final vote thanks to
everybody who has joined me throughout
the impeachment hearings we did get 178
people signed up with the coupon code
impeach 50 the goal of 200 was ambitious
178 is nothing to sneeze at we will be
back with a brand new show tomorrow
including coverage reaction